last time you saw how cloud operations
can help you quickly isolate or
eliminate infrastructure issues
from a limited set of data you also saw
how to quickly filter
alerts to determine whether your service
is being impacted by an infrastructure
issue
but how can you identify problems with
the service itself and when there's a
problem how can you quickly triage and
mitigate it
today i'm going to show you how to
manage services running on gke with
cloud operations
welcome to engineering for reliability
with google cloud
does this look familiar it's really hard
to determine if your service is actually
healthy from infrastructure signals like
these
in chapter 6 of the sre book we say that
your monitoring system should address
two questions
what's broken and why signals from your
infrastructure may tell you why
something is happening
but they don't tell you anything about
the reliability of your service itself
as
experienced by users to understand that
you need good service level
indicators or slis that measures service
reliability
and service level objectives or slos
that set specific reliability targets
we looked at how to configure an slo for
a service running on gk by using load
balancer metrics back in episode two
we'll link to it if you didn't get a
chance to watch it so what happens when
there's a problem
let's have a look at how cloud
operations can help you figure out what
to do
let's start on the services overview
page we can see that we have a service
with an slo alert firing
in this case our service is running on
gke let's have a look at the gke
dashboard to see what's going on
here we can see that we have an
unhealthy slo for this kubernetes
service
let's have a closer look here's our slo
and the alert letting us know we're
burning error budget right now
we can also confirm that our sli is
severely degraded
what could be happening in the metrics
tab
we can see that the pod name was
recently changed
and this seems to correspond to when the
alert fired so
something has changed let's try to
figure out what
let's go to the gke workload screen and
look at the workload that we're running
when we look at the revision history for
the workload
we can see that a new revision was
rolled out a few minutes before the
alert fired
this may be our culprit let's roll this
release back and see if that restores
our service back to a healthy state
that we've rolled back that release
let's check the state of our workload
under revision history we can confirm
that we've rolled back to a known good
version
let's go to services and confirm that
the air budget burn alert is no longer
firing
when we check the status of our service
we can see that the slo is no longer
firing an alert
and our sli has also recovered so
we were able to identify a problem with
our service running on gke
determined that it was caused by a bad
rollout and rolled back to a known good
state to recover the health of our
service
thanks for joining me today we saw how
cloud operations can help you quickly
triage and mitigate application issues
for services running at gk i hope this
helps you keep your applications
reliable and keep your users happy
thanks so much for watching don't forget
to like and subscribe to never miss out
on more engineering for reliability with
google cloud
see you soon
you